as a result of this hybrid war of the entire
collective West against Russia,
which was unleashed by hands,
bodies and all
other components of Ukrainian
society against us using
more modern technology, Russia has become
significantly stronger this year and the unity of
our
[music]
cart has been delivered, demilitarization denazification will be
implemented
from this nowhere  not to leave We are
actively working with developing
countries,
especially in the context of the fact that the West is
really now changing its
tactics, maybe even thinking about
clarifying the strategy. Because if the
strategic defeat of Russia is a
strategy, forgive the tautology, then this
strategy failed miserably, everyone
already understands this a week
ago, even  a little more than 10 days ago,
another such
meeting of the seven plus the leading
developing countries took place where not all the
countries of the majority of the world participated;
some refused the
invitations, but it was held in complete
secrecy; nothing was reported about it anywhere
and no leaks
were made; they agreed to hold another meeting
in January And in February there will be a whole
world summit where this Zelensky formula
will be
approved